[Music]
the issue border security the wedge the
partial government shutdown the
collateral damage federal employees who
didn't get a paycheck yesterday yet they
refused to negotiate sit for serious
talks or work for the safety and
security of the American people their
mantra there is no crisis at our open
porous borders their goal destroy Donald
Trump and yesterday reports are and even
larger caravan is staging in Honduras
about to cause an even greater burden on
our Border Patrol and the system at
large the president has shown he is
capable of negotiating he has gone from
a concrete wall to a steel slab barrier
willing to go with any barrier any
physical barrier that you cannot climb
over crawl under rappel
or shoot yourself out of a cannon over
he's made concessions from 25 billion to
5 billion from a concrete barrier to a
steel one promising more personnel
detention beds using technology and
electronics to buttress the security and
money to address the humanitarian needs
in spite of his negotiating the
Democrats refused to budge but curiously
there are some Democrats peeling away
from the rigid non-negotiable stance of
Nancy Pelosi well I can tell you we've
had fencing in the past I'm sure we will
in the future if there are places where
wall makes sense but there are a lot of
places where it doesn't some fencing
you're saying is useful some fencing is
uses some barriers are useful if we have
a partial wall if we have fencing if we
have technology used to keep our borders
safe all of that is fine well you have
to see what you're talking about here
does it contribute
in a smart way to our security certain
physical barriers can make sense along
the border and in a lot of places you
already have that I have a solution
there is no question that President
Trump has the authority to declare a
national emergency the controlling case
is Youngstown Sheet and tube versus
Sawyer three four three u.s. five
seventy nine the critical operational
issue is that only money already
authorized and appropriated by Congress
can be spent the only serious source of
funds are in the military construction
bill this week there was some debate
whether that money would come from a
line item of thirteen point 1 billion
dollars covering housing in Afghanistan
and Iraq or a thirteen point nine
billion dollar line for disaster relief
now clearly the thirteen point 1 billion
should be the line used since I doubt we
need to build homes in Afghanistan and
Iraq but now expect the Democrats to go
forum-shopping if that happens in
California where the appeal goes
directly to the liberal 9th circus
circuit if the president declares an
emergency using the military
construction funds assume they will win
but on an appeal to the Supreme Court of
the United States they will lose under
youngstown so the only question now is
whether or not this is a national
emergency and if you don't think another
caravan of thousands moving in a highly
organized fashion similar to military
convoys with an advanced party a main
body in a rear party that has exhibited
violence along the way with migrants in
addition to those from Central America
from Africa Pakistan Yemen Afghanistan
India Bangladesh Nepal and more is a
national emergency then you're out
out-crazy the president has been sitting
in the Oval Office since Christmas Eve
he's ready if the Democrats aren't
coming to the table the time to declare
a national emergency is now and that's
my open if you like my opening
statements you'll love my new book New
York Times number-one bestseller
liars leakers and liberals the case
against the anti Trump conspiracy